edinburgh's royal mile
deserted under lockdown but with just a
faint echo of events that have taken
place here
over the past decade marching for
scottish independence
before a referendum in which scots voted
to remain
part of the united kingdom and later
voting for continued membership
of the european union but brexit has
changed
everything and independence is once more
in the air what we were told at that
time was that
if we stayed in the united kingdom that
would be staying in the european union
our rights as eu citizens would be
respected and of course that's been
completely ignored
the opportunity now is to have an
independence on on a referendum
on independence to take us back into
europe
to realize that that is our destiny and
ask the people of scotland to complete
the powers
of the scottish parliament in order to
achieve that prime minister boris
johnson treats
calls for another referendum on
independence with disdain
we had a referendum on the issue in 2014
uh which uh senior members of your party
perhaps not you
you uh said was a once in a generation
event it was on that basis
uh the people voted in the way that they
did very substantially to keep our
wonderful union
together boris johnson is loathed by
scottish nationalists who see him as the
embodiment of brexit an entitled
englishman who pays only
lip service to the importance of the
union so his pitch
to build back better together after the
pandemic rings
hollow here among those who voted
heavily to remain
in the european union and who now would
vote to leave the united kingdom
but there's a catch the very thing
brexit
that has taken support for independence
to new heights
is also the thing that makes
independence seem economically
unviable so on the one hand brexit acts
as a an as an accelerator on
independence preferences
because people are not happy not being
in the european union
but at the same time an independent
scotland outside of the eu
but also finding that has difficulty
trading with
um with its former trade partners in the
terms in
in the form of the rest of the uk well
that that also is is a problem so it
makes people want independence more
but it makes in some ways the economic
consequences of independence
far more severe than they were in 2014
but those arguments haven't dented
voting intentions
yet 18 opinion polls in a row
show a firm lead for independence and an
expected landslide win for the scottish
nationalists
in may's parliamentary election could
yet create
an unstoppable democratic force
now even if those opinion polls continue
to hold up and
even if the scottish national party is
expected wins its biggest victory
ever in parliamentary elections in may
that doesn't automatically guarantee
a yes win if indeed there is to be
another vote on the question
of independence and that's because of
that economic conundrum that i outlined
there now take
uh the scottish language industry as an
example struggling now to get its
product to markets in the eu
to france because of new trade rules
because of red tape consider
that they move that product through
english sports indeed a lot of that
product
is sold in england and you get this
picture of an independent scotland
outside of the eu outside of the uk and
key
with no guarantee of being able to
re-enter
the european union as an independent
nation and that all could be
economically ruinous which is why one
haulier that i spoke to preparing to set
off with his uh
load of langoustine trying to get it to
france said in his heart
he believes in independence in his head
not so much
jonah thanks very much